years after disney's acquisition of
lucasfilm the release of new star wars
movies and tv series has become
something of a regular occurrence in the
early days of disney star wars however
the franchise's new owners handled the
property at a comparatively slower pace
using their knowledge of the force to
build huge levels of anticipation before
each release that's not how the force
works
[Music]
the first two entries in disney's star
wars trilogy then were all the more
important at the time of their release
given that they provided fans with some
of their first insights into the
franchise's current era among the key
contributions of those early films was
the introduction of rey portrayed by
newcomer daisy ridley as rey adam driver
also stars opposite ridley as a
villainous kylo ren a dark side jedi as
well as the son of han solo and princess
leia in an interview with oh my disney
driver discussed what it was like
working with ridley on disney's first
two skywalker saga films sharing some
rare insight into the real-life human
being behind one of the early pillars of
modern star wars
amidst the larger behind-the-scenes
discussion about their time spent making
star wars the force awakens and the last
jedi oh my disney asked daisy ridley and
adam driver each what their experience
was like working with the other
performer according to driver ridley was
a wholly positive presence on set both
in their personal interactions and in
her acting work it's easy to be in
scenes with her because i could i could
listen to her
you know all day she has just great
instincts for what it's worth ridley
spoke of acting opposite driver in
similarly glowing terms he is so amazing
in this film
seriously i can't speak highly enough
about him so in the very basic sense of
it all he is the most amazing scene
partner by all indications ridley
appears to be someone alongside whom
driver had a great time working on set
as it turns out adam driver's time spent
working with daisy ridley ended up
blossoming into a full-fledged
friendship among a number of other
topics some related to star wars some
not the two further discussed their
relationship with one another in an
interview published by v magazine in
fact it wasn't so much an interview as a
remote conversation between the two i'd
rather not do this now
yeah me too
why did you hate your father
at one point in their conversation in
response to a question about whether or
not she prefers meeting her co-stars
prior to filming ridley mentioned that
she and driver eventually became great
friends the reason it took so long well
it wasn't because they didn't enjoy
being with each other on set as ridley
said in the interview adam we became
besties last year but we had met some
years before it really takes me a while
to relax with people i don't think i'm
very good at meeting people i feel
awfully uncomfortable considering the
interview's 2017 publication date this
means that they most likely became
official besties at some point during
their time spent on the set of the last
jedi together in response driver told
her quote you always seemed very open
directly complimenting her personality
once again and agreeing that he also had
trouble being comfortable with new
people driver also jokingly asked ridley
is there an aspect of working on star
wars it could be anything from the
lightsaber battles the travel the
catering to getting to see me every day
and do my hair that was your favorite
part to which ridley replied that quote
becoming besties with driver had been
the highlight of the whole thing it
certainly seems like the two have fun
talking to each other and it sounds like
they had a great time on set finally at
the very end of their conversation
driver once again praised ridley's skill
as a performer signing off by telling
her quote i think you're brilliant their
discussion in v magazine showcases how
the two performers speak of one another
in glowing terms while keeping the
atmosphere around them light-hearted all
the while check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]